hello welcome to this video playing
sauerkraut as love coach it Chuck so we
probably will get a king's indian by
transposition or not place is six
sometimes ok call it more oxy all rights
good news I like that I prefer the
positions a little bit more with them
the bishop coming to and sorry with the
night coming to a c2 but this is the
classical main line and also of course
perfectly fine for white and it's not so
bad for black even let us know what a
mite what am I talking you this is not
bad for black though let's try like that
okay Queen there
like this at quincy one is right i am a
forgotten detail CM a four and i don't
think that is possible but why why is
that not good
I can't be takes a four is probably not
right and I don't see why that is bad
there's some trick that I don't see here
all right I did something wrong of
course it's possible but I don't know
what okay I just play something normal
hmm not sure how to take care to be
honest absolutely not
now Blake is like a yeah absolutely I
added something wrong probably not quite
sure what but he I don't have anything
some rugae 30 I know
94 we can just do ocoee he enters hmm
that's a bit surprising okay I don't
mind dad
I bishop wasn't that great anyway I
maybe just rookie 7th good of Kalki 70
it's not it's not a bad move my ideas
brooksy seven anyway I'll rook c8
sometimes for Bishop age 6 that doesn't
threaten anything to be honest sure
probably played Roxy seven anyway right
as it's not bad I like my position here
my king is more active and I also have
the slightly favor of porn structure yep
this is in fact a bit annoying yes to I
can take and place them
if it takes i co-wrote p8 at the end and
take that pawn
Mary Bishop age six was interesting
check
he wants to bring the King up I'm not
quite sure what to do i think i'll take
just have a look at seven so that King
you five is not so easy
you
h4 maybe the ship takes Bishop g5 I just
got King e5 hmm that's not good okay
maybe I should have actually played that
differently certainly and was it that
wasn't a particularly great technical
plane do I get some somewhere around
there
hmm time morning I don't get my
membership is not able to do much him
what a strange game again I get counter
a tag on there five pawn
30 seconds and it's not good yeah that's
a good structure I get def porn I think
check I shall come back actually no okay
I can I thought you would pin me but
maybe that wasn't working check check
check check check check check check
check check no I'm losing on time yet
yeah well that's too bad I'm that's too
bad from a very nice position and add
more time Eve yeah I make this mistake
it's 17 against 13 and try to find a win
and there is one somewhere but I just
have to play quick moves and and see
that I win was with the time yeah I just
I still want to play good moves and this
is this is costing me games losing that
was really completely unnecessary yeah
he probably had drawn check because I I
don't see how to make
any headway it's a bit of a shame
somehow I got got a good position out of
this Jam ya got the beep horn and I was
technically difficult for me I wasn't
sure how to do that and it worked out
okay though I mean jack yeah it gets
nice I had reared rupee 3 here yeah that
was kind of mysterious that he didn't do
that its lucky for me that I have this
so that i can still wrong hunted here
jack yeah yeah i should win but I should
prefer to Vinod time especially doing
this on position is not so easy and I
spent too much time trying to be non
position and then lose on time if like
here we either had a couple of seconds
up he spent some time around here okay
yeah this 17 against this is I should
just be no time okay thanks for watching